Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 219. To David P.
We got a great voicemail of support. We already
talked earlier about all of the insane things
happening. Sean hannity, donald trump jr.
Candace owens sending the right wing mob
against me. We talked about what's going on with
advertisers, some advertisers sticking with us,
some advertisers bailing, etc., etc.. Here's
just a single message. And I got a ton of these
a single message of support from a viewer.
Speaker 3: David. My name is Steve and I'm
calling just to tell you to hang in there, be
encouraged. You're going to come out on top
of this and I will support you in any way that I
can. Thank you. The lesson here for a long time.
I've never had a problem. What I've
heard you say. I think you're pretty,
right? I'm pretty sharp. And I get a kick out
of you sometimes. Okay. Thank you. David. We
need you. We need you. Don't be discouraged.
Speaker 1: Thank you. I can't tell you how much
I appreciate that. A powerful message of support
against the hate mob. So where do we stand right
now? The antagonistic messages have started to
slow down to some degree instead of a message once
a second. It's now like every 15 seconds. Now,
that doesn't sound. I know it doesn't sound that
great. David, That's good. Every 15 seconds. It is
better than what it was. And we will see where we
are by the time Monday lands. I told you we lost
a couple of advertisers. I don't know where we're
going to land, but I hope that this caller is is
exactly correct. We have such a great bonus show
for you today. A rift in the Republican Party
has been exposed as senators are warning Kevin
McCarthy against this Iraq vote that is being
discussed. We're going to discuss what's going on,
who might vote, which way and what Republican
senators are up to. The FDA in the United States
has approved the over-the-counter sale of Narcan,
which is an overdose reversal drug. This is widely
seen as a great thing. While some are concerned
that it will encourage overdosing because, hey,
you can just grab over-the-counter Narcan
and have it with you. We will talk about
both sides of the discussion. And Adidas or
Adidas, as some of our friends pronounce it,
has retracted their opposition to the Black Lives
Matter three stripe design. What is this about?
What's the back story? What's the controversy? I
will tell you all about it on today's bonus show.
Two great ways to access the bonus show. First
and foremost. Sign up it. Join pack Mint.com.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show
where you want to make money.
Speaker 2: And everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is.
Speaker 1: Bad. Sir? Yes, sir. Sign up
at join Pacman dot com. You can use the
coupon code. Cancel. Cancel. That's all
one word. Cancel. Cancel. Meaning cancel
the counselors trying to cancel us right now.
Second option. You make a pledge on Patreon
of at least five bucks a month. You can find
that at Patria CNN.com slash The David Pakman
Show. We will see you on the bonus show. And
I will be back tomorrow with the Friday show.